sold four thousand of these i can give  you the best play in the world and the  you know best training best nutrition  but if you don't show up it doesn't  matter right right okay cool so the  reason that we have such a high success  rate your three forms of accountability  one is that you have peer-to-peer  accountability of other people you're  gonna be starting with who are in the  same spot as you next you have alumni  accountability so people further ahead  of you who are going to be pulling you  and cheering you ahead because they've  done it and then you've got expert  accountability from the coaches who've  done this 100 times and the last one and  the most important one people basically  make a bet on themselves and so you pay  500 you do everything you hit the goal  we'll give you the whole thing back  pretty much the explanation